this is mines my previa I've talked
before about the fact that I wanted to
get the whole course sort of under our
belt in sort of basic form if your life
before I went back and looked at some of
the more detailed aspects of it so
that's why today we're coming back to
one of the elements under that comes
under databases okay and as as we
mentioned our query by example comes up
in HSE exists it's one of the most
important frequently mentioned topics
but it sort of comes in parallel to SQL
in more ways than one and so when we
were learning I thought okay I'll just
get you guys to master SQL first and
then when you get to QBE you'll
appreciate it a little more
all right so start this fall I'll
describe the motivation behind qvs
development well to explain that let's
get back to this because I said that
query by examples mentor was sort of
developed in parallel with structured
query language okay now let's take back
how much do you still have up there in
your brain how do you how do you write a
query in SQL
maybe there's four things okay okay
first select now select select what good
good so you might choose a identify a
field out of the database right so you
might say slit name and address right
and then what was the next thing I have
to select from and what does that
identify that's right so for instance it
might be on the students table okay all
right now two more usually that's lost
what's the next one we're good
so where is where we introduced a
condition right so for instance you
might say I want all of the names right
you might want them all to be similar
like say side with a
okay so that would do it right using
this wild card
and then lastly comes order by okay and
so we might put it by what I don't say
name I said do adds a pretty typical
query yeah now just look at that um you
guys understand this because we've
learnt this already right but actually
number one this is quite hard to buy so
we spent ages trying to learn all these
see what they all meant and number two
it's not just hard to understand but
it's also very easy to mess up right if
you get a single character wrong in this
for instance suppose instead of saying
students you forgot that it was like you
know plural so you call it student okay
the whole thing just melts down okay
because that's the nature of how
computers work they're like you know you
get one character on and it will get
it'll mess up everything
or if you have select from where order
by Fiat something slightly wrong there
again the computer would just barf on
you okay so engineers actually one
particular engineer here worked at IBM
and his name is so awesome it's kind of
like it's it looks like a day that you
would make up but it's a real guy ah
mush a sleuth it seriously sounded like
a day that's how I made up but we got
he's a good girl why should I share me
heads yeah yeah who don't anyway this
guy he said look when you when you want
to get data out of a database you have
to go through this awkward way of doing
it right so not just it's awkward it's
hard to understand it's easy to get it
wrong okay so he said look why don't we
design something that's a little more
visual right so QBE is often called a
visual method for retrieving data
okay now before we unpack that a little
more remember what I'm trying to answer
is what's the motivation behind
cubies development okay so basically
number one you wanted to make it easier
to get data out okay you wanted to make
it easier and secondly he wanted to
allow users to actually use this
language without necessarily
understanding it okay you want to allow
users to use SQL without having you know
done HSC apt and having to work on
understanding okay what are all these
bits me use SQL without understanding
and ever it sound a bit terrible you're
like no we should always understand
things before we use them right but I
mean the nature of the world and the
nature of your life is that you use tons
of things that you do not understand
right for us that's just simple example
uh you guys all know it's a good thing
to eat fiber right but why but why is
that because someone told you okay
yeah I care that you I hope I hope you
studied it in life PE or maybe they
don't admire but the point is we do lots
of things that are good without
understanding them okay and SQL is
really really useful but lots of people
were having trouble you see it just
because it was difficult understand
right